gee Allah if only one what a memories
his messenger Allah Allah there's only
one where Jesus was his messenger Allah
is Salam alaikum greetings a piece
Ricardo how you doing welcome to the D
show something that how are you how you
been
I'm glad live in life and loving it
life is grand let me ask you the first
question everyone's dying to know when
someone accepts Islam like why why did
you you you obviously you weren't from a
family that was Muslim right right out
there's an athlete yes grew up Catholic
why'd you accept Islam very good
question um someone introduced me to it
I was very intrigued I spent about seven
and a half months studying it intensely
I'm in seven eleven and a half month
this wasn't like just an emotional day
or not it was every day I studied I
asked questions I read the Quran in
about a week when I got my hands on it
and the truth just hit me like a brick
and I embraced it some story some short
condensed version some people I mean
they're born in a Muslim family never
read the Quran right right they called
Muslims on batteries have you heard that
one yeah we're just Ramadan Moses or not
but you actually you read it in a week
in a week yeah over than cut it down I
couldn't put it down
how'd you get ahold of it I just went to
this bookstore and bought it why because
I wanted to read it for myself and
understand what's in it um how long ago
was this well I became Muslim in 1995 so
this is in the spring ish of 95 yeah
what was it unlike now right like
nowadays it's not you know there's trend
yet things was a trendy back then to be
know as where are those like rappers
that were like kind of you know cool if
you were looking up to the arc I don't
know the arc yeah no there was nothing
like that at the time that at least not
that I remember and this is pre 9/11 so
the whole Islamic
awareness in the world was very very low
is very low-key low-key do you think
that would have impacted your decision
if it was like if that situation was
happening now as it was done you think
that you know that's a very good
question I'd like to think that not
because I'm beholding to the truth and
when you're beholden to the truth I had
to be honest with you if I look at my
life I grew up in this neighborhood and
I hear a condo in Chicago grew up in the
north side here and I was running around
here acting a fool I had every incentive
to ignore religion and just go on living
you know la vida loca
or lovely those like crazy lies yes vida
loca
what's that Ricky Martin written songs
yeah and so really it's all about what
what you what you hold fast to which
will we could probably get into later
about you know the topic of discussion
because it ties into that a lot now you
came from a CAF because you're what you
have what part of the Latino you have
were Tory kill my father's Mexican Max
and my mother's Puerto Rican okay Lori
quoi that's hippo Rican yes and how they
take a custom to you because yeah well
when my brother and I actually took
Shahada at the same time and your
brother yes older younger he's younger
by one year we're like Irish twins so we
came home and we broke the news to our
parents it was about 7:00 in the in the
evening and it turned into a fight until
like 4:00 in the morning and okay thank
the picture for us all right so you're
let's back it up again now what was it
were you on a spiritual journey what was
going on in your life that you wanted to
pick up the Quran that you also now many
people don't question the faith that
they're upon right the realization is
all the same and they just blend in you
know slide it on very good question so
when I was a teenager I Karen sir not
very religious somewhere in the
neighborhood of when I was 15 16 my
parents start to become more religious
and they urged us to you know follow you
know more in their newfound sort of
discovery of being religious and at the
time I thought well why you know what's
the point
what God if God God knows I am a good
person why do I need to pray to prove it
so I'd a lot of questions as a young man
eventually right around the age of 18 I
said about trying to answer that
question and I studied a lot of
religions just just to get the idea of
God or not out of my head I wanted to
settle is there a god you know should I
care or is it's just all about science
and evolution so that was my first step
and I studied many religions Buddhism
Buddhism Judaism all kinds of things but
I never studied Islam which is
interesting yeah at this time I came to
the conclusion that all religions are a
different road to God and you pick pick
whatever is good for you and I chose to
remain a Catholic and when I read when I
read the New Testament I was very
touched by the stories in the sayings of
esata he said I am Jesus yes and I
became a devout Catholic so I would go
to church every Sunday I prayed every
night and this is you know just my own
thing I you know I still didn't live any
any kind of conservative lifestyle you
know but spiritually I was really in
tune and then this went on for a couple
years and then a friend of mine who's a
Latino he's a Colombian Mexican who had
become a Muslim introduced me to Islam
told me the most basic thing that I
didn't know and it took about 10 seconds
to tell me the following he said God
sent Moses and from the teachings of
Moses came Judaism he said then God sent
Jesus from teachers teachings of Jesus
came Christianity he goes then God sent
Muhammad and by the way at that moment
when he said God said Muhammad this
thing like when often like God sent
Muhammad you know he said from the
teachings of Muhammad came Islam and I'm
like thinking okay is it up to up until
that point I thought maja Muhammadan
Islam had absolutely nothing to do with
Christianity or Judaism I thought it was
a completely you know mutual
the exclusive religion here's a guy in
the desert that did something became a
good leader among the Arabs create a
religion that was my impression of Islam
at a time so when he said then God sent
Mohammed God sent Muhammad then he went
back and he said in Islam we believe in
Jesus Moses Abraham the angel Gabriel I
you guys believe in the angel Gabriel
yes believe in Jesus you guys and I was
just absolutely blown away and having
been through the studies of many
religions previously it was very natural
for me to then just study one more now
how I was guided you know al awwalin how
are we gonna only only God knows how I
was why I was guided in this way perhaps
I needed a pre transformation before I
was introduced to Islam and the rest is
history from there I just went on this
seven and a half month long study
intense and it entailed some heartbreak
because you know when you're when you're
already devout some people come to Islam
they weren't really deeply connected to
their original whatever their spiritual
affinity affinity was and some people
are really really devoutly faithful and
when that happens you first have to
undergo a sort of heartbreak and it's
very difficult it's a very difficult
time yeah but I got through it and I
just wanted the truth and you know I was
guided and I'm happy I'm happy never
looked back it's the best thing that's
ever happened to me that's what people
should like you just said truth be out
for truth and sometimes it's like a
filtration process some things and you
have to relearn in the essence of
learning some things you learn and
they're not necessarily right so you
have to be willing to relearn some
things let go of some things absolutely
and if and if the goal is truth you're
going to have an easier time and what I
like in many people they like is I just
make sense like you mentioned Moses and
then from there you know the people
stemmed off and they started they
created this Judaism which Moses he
never he never preached taught Jesus
never taught Christianity or called
people to worship Him but they all
submitted themselves to God like Abraham
he whereas God Almighty says he was in
the Jew or Christian but he was one who
submitted himself to God so that just
makes sense all the prophets they
submitted themselves to God that's just
one word in Arabic Islam submission to
the will of God that's all I want to do
I want to keep it simple I don't want to
pray to a human being
I want to pray to st. idols icon statues
just to God rightful right some people
get fat they get blown away it can't be
that simple but it's not simple it is it
is in them and you know what's what's
fascinating about this journey was that
I was praying to God to help me defend
my religion help me defend Jesus help me
defend the Bible and every day some I
would discover something new to the
contrary and I would have certain
questions but we know I go to bed that
night and I well what about
such-and-such and you know go to sleep
the next day the very first thing I
would find is the answer that question I
mean was really uncanny now when you say
you you were print you're praying to God
what do you mean very good question you
know a lot of people ask me how do you
how do you think that why do you think
you were guided why do you think that
you were sort of chosen you know it's
God's will whom whom he guides and I
could say that the one reason why I
think I discovered Islam and was allowed
to embrace it is because as a Catholic
it just didn't make sense to me to pray
to Jesus give you about him I always
felt like okay so I did believe in the
Trinity I believe that there's a Father
the Son the Holy Spirit but in total you
believe that of course at the time
before I knew anything about Islam I
wholeheartedly believed in the Trinity
but intuitively I directed my prayers to
the father I didn't really direct my
prayers to the son yeah you know so I
had a sort of element of tawheed in me
and it's just one nosov uniqueness of
the one God even though I was practicing
something you know the partnership of
God and I think that that is probably
when I say I prayed to God
you could buy in my mind I was directing
my prayers to the Father yeah as a
Catholic - without intermediaries you I
did not direct my prayers to Jesus yeah
in my mind in my heart that is what I
believe and in talking I have some
experience in talking to people that was
the turning point in their life when
people asked the crater alone God
Almighty
he eyed them he guided them yes but as
soon as they started to put a partner
next to God they started to put an
intermediary between them and God does
stop the guidance but when they did what
you did just pray to God alone guide me
guide me guide me the guidance came it
did it did and and this is all in
hindsight at the time I did not
understand the importance of this it was
just an intuitive thing that I did yeah
that's what it that's what I did we're
more we got more people got to do that
that's not as a lowly human comes
natural because these things are taught
you know I think I think Christians
ought to do it even as an experiment
have you thought about go you go to the
you know go to like in Spanish we say
it's done you know there's the Donny
this is the the main guy you know if I
say for example if you want to raise do
you go to the employee or do you go to
the boss good point
no you go to the boss for a raise and
just as an experiment just try it you
know God if you you know if you want if
you really want to guide me to whatever
the truth is ask God directly in your
mind in your heart and put everything
else aside Jesus the Holy Spirit put it
aside put everyone else to the side see
what happened what's the one who created
you we'll take a break and be right back
with more don't go anywhere
welcome back to the D show on some great
advice I love it some real simple easy
to do because we're here for a short
time we don't know when the conductor is
going to call our number we're on a
train and you have to get off to the
next stop and that's the next life and
it doesn't make sense we just die and
then what just turn a dust and that's
what Islam calls us to think about the
reality of this life that it's short you
thought about it was the purpose of life
where we going when we die and it just
makes sense to ask the one who's the
owner of life who created life to guide
us like you did you become a Muslim one
who submits to the will of God and now
as I say often all hell breaks loose at
the house and cat home yes and your
brother were you guys like doing this
simultaneously you and your brother yeah
so my brother he tell you about it you
told no I told him about it so I did all
the work and I would just come and tell
him about it and he trusts trusted me
and just followed follow along with me
but I pretty much did all the work yeah
now I'm going to kind of jump around a
little bit you you also you went through
some you got married yes shortly after
or were you were married at the time no
I was not married at the time I married
later how much later did you get married
I'm at about 26 years old if I remember
let me see 20 20 28 now there's some
struggles I mean it's like you come into
Islam now you got to do some
housecleaning
right let's say you might have had some
stuff up you know some Saints and stuff
you gotta get rid of all that all right
you got it maybe your fridge maybe you
got some alcohol some wine coolers you
gotta get rid of that some simple
cleaning some adjustments maybe you were
yes people would pray through Jesus now
you praying to the one Jesus pray to
simple stuff maybe you had some bad
character a cuss words people cursing
and swearing not keeping your promises
you gotta make some final adjustments
right absolutely you're carrying some
baggage from the past and some of us are
still it's it's a lifetime struggle to
become a better anything it is that's
absolutely right sometimes we get into
relationships now and we think okay now
Muslim the struggle stops did it
continue of course the struggles
continued yeah and you know old habits
die hard
some people are able to
undergo a massive transformation astir
short amount of time they kind of jump
in you know two feet I was more of a
gradual adjuster you know I didn't begin
saying uh doing all my prayers or on
time and you know it took it took time
to work the the way of life into my
character and my habits but how long did
it take until you you establish the
prayer in your life um five times a day
how long it took years to be on here of
you it took years I've been Muslim now
for 22 years
it took somewhere between five and seven
years in Grenoble - well I'm alright
even going to the dirt once you
establish it big difference yes big
difference in the difference that I can
see now and again this is now in
hindsight is that it wasn't until after
I made these changes and made them
permanent that some rather life-altering
things happen to me for example you know
a divorce is an example sometimes
they're bad sometimes you know people
don't fix something unless they
understand it's broken yeah and you know
when we undergo a calamity in our lives
it's actually a blessing you know when
people people think that when you pray
when you you know when you give in
charity and you fast that the
expectation is that your life in this
world is going to improve that's not
necessarily true
because sometimes what you actually need
is to hit a calamity in order to wake
you up and either seek answers or be
directed in a way that's better for you
plus we all know that when you suffer
you're actually wiping out bad deeds in
your book so there's a double benefit
you know you're you're cleaning up some
bad deeds and taking care of your
accounts in this world which is much
better and at the same time you're
you're being directed to something else
so you know I would say that
it hasn't all been bad but since then
it's that's that's when the the
important events in my life that have
happened is after establishing your
prayer and being more committed to being
a better a better Muslim it reminds me
of and that's why like when you take
time you study the history the study of
the righteous predecessors and people
who at that time were lost pleased with
them you know these other people they
accepted Islam there's so many valuable
stories for example when the boycott
happened in Mecca how would these people
like try to connect like okay we just
accepted a truth now we're being
boycotted we're eating leaves
we're like being oppressed and at the
end of the day you'd think like hold on
the truth why am i eating leaves like
they had no yeah boy kata they're being
oppressed but at the end they became
victorious so many people like through
the struggles now no way can you equate
many of this everyone has their own
obviously individual struggles and we
don't not undermining those many people
when things get really tough and those
things are meant to make us not break us
you went through some of those troubles
and through those struggles that you
went through you went on exploration now
a journey of seeking more knowledge and
you didn't just like leave your Deen
absolutely some people Muslims even they
end up hitting this really deep area in
their life and they just you know
struggle that they just can't wrap their
mind around why is this happening to me
why why why why why I just said what's
up to the truth why they can't
understand it
nor do they grow from it they limit
themselves and they lose patience and
they lose the Deen they do and they look
they lose the practice and you know I'll
tell you what's scary yeah is if you're
not practicing even if you're not Muslim
if you're just not spiritual and things
are going well in your life that's scary
because what that could possibly mean is
that Ilan has mercy is giving you your
paradise in this life because you're not
going to getting anything in in the next
life because that's what you chose you
know so when if you're not praying if
you're not fasting if
you're not accepting the oneness of God
and you you do have a good life and
you're not suffering things because God
is not giving you the calamities that
lead you to a better guidance so when
you are suffering drama in your life we
should look at it as a mercy this is you
know the you know the Quran talks about
the sailors in the sea who won that when
the waves rise up like canopies over
their ships their hearts are very very
sincere and when when God says their
hearts are sincere he knows every little
iota of what is in your heart so that is
a very profound statement for God to say
that your heart is very sincere these
are sailors who and at any other time
didn't care about God but in that moment
they were very sincere in their in their
supplication save us save us and but but
then it says when they get back to the
land right they go back to their old
ways and forget about God but you know
the point is is that the calamity of the
sea brought them closer to God and this
is how the calamities are in life so if
you're not suffering calamities that's a
and you're not praying and doing the
right thing that's that's pretty scary
to me have you seen have you you have
any people that you've known friends or
anybody that they were in the deen and
really pressed seem like they're from
the outside it was like wow the brother
grew his beard he's like you know really
seem like he's at the Masjid praying but
now like where's his brother he's back
at the club he's maybe got some you know
pictures of him you know doing some
things or the sister she was in the cop
she was like really full force you
follow me and all of a sudden it's off
it's totally gone she's even just like
downgrade AJ or she just took everything
like completely fell off everything is
off completely fell off the wagon what
what what happens you know the way that
I've come to understand this phenomenon
it really goes back to this very simple
principle and let me just say shine and
I don't want to I'm just painting his
picture because it's not all about just
the appearance it's really about you
know
don't worry yeah so I'm just painting
this too you know so people can it
because that's what we attribute but
it's not just about the facade it's
really more about the exact well go
ahead and you know you're hitting the
nail on the head I mean the
principle is that and this goes back to
psychology you know and how it ties into
the Dean and it really is boils down to
this if there is anything external to me
that modifies my sense of value as a
person if I say hey Eddie do you think
you're a good guy and you say yeah I
think I'm a good guy I'm a good person
you know why why do you think you're a
good guy now whatever the answer to that
question is is going to be many there
going to be many reasons on this and
that I do this I do that whatever if any
of those things net lists are external
to you then then they're mean means that
there are external factors that modify
your value your perception of yourself
some things are internal well the
internal things are things like honesty
patience gentleness intelligence
external things are like things like
money your looks your status your your
degree you know you have a PhD your
title yes these are all external things
the more these external things make you
feel good or bad it leads to disaster
uh-huh this is by the way this is - this
is in the core of the what modern-day
psychologists consider a healthy
psychology and it happens to be at the
core of the Deen as well yeah so when
you look at you know how the Quran has
many scientific revelations well a lot
of people don't know is that the Quran
also has a lot of psychological
revelations yeah and it's very
fascinating but that's what it is if
people are tied to external factors then
that's when you will see that the facade
is not what it is on the inside what did
you just prove that through that was
that because now the let's say the
sister who was wearing you know
implementing the deen and then now she's
on you know whatever snapchat or what
and she's people are like she's holding
up the Hennessy bottle was that that at
the end was her her love for that what
she she thinks now that leads to
happiness right that was so
connected to you know the facade of
happiness that it goes back to what
you're saying these material things and
that's material temporary and it won't
be anything external another is Astor
another person is external to you one of
the biggest problems is approval seeking
so if I'm worried about you know what
how you perceive me as a person if
that's what's important to me then I'm
going to sacrifice the internal things
I'm going to sacrifice my integrity
internally in order to craft my image
because I need you to I need your
perception to be good of me I need you
to think I'm a good guy yeah so you know
there are variations of what an external
focus is versus in in billion being
extrinsically to a focus versus
intrinsically focused and what you see
on the outside is the route is usually
because there's some external focus that
lead that person to go and do these
things and they sacrifice the truth they
sacrifice what is what is correct I want
to ask you some more questions when they
come back having a nice conversation
with Riccardo here and through your
journey you also you learn some valuable
lessons we're going to touch upon those
when we come back and she'll log on
woman don't go anywhere
back here on a gene show Ricardo you
took a very valuable lesson or lessons
through your your marriage you were
talking somewhat and people then coming
to you what was a friend's family and
they trust in your advice that you kind
of you've been giving people and through
your experiences and that's the thing
like that's fascinating someone can have
a feel that they're there in right but
they didn't experience all of these
other things they didn't hit they didn't
go through the grind that someone might
went to and you really went through a
grind I did yeah and you learned a lot
and people are really benefiting friends
and other colleagues and people who
you've shared some your experiences with
and they're like really trying to get
you to write a book about it yeah sure I
talked to us about this so I went
through a time in my life where I began
to do a lot of self development and
trying to figure out what it is where it
is that I need to improve and some
answers about relationships in
particular and what I found was
absolutely astonishing the interesting
thing was that the information that I
found was scattered in different places
and I also had to figure out what was
good information what was bad
information and I put this all together
in terms of like an understanding in my
head
and over time I you know I implemented
it in my own life became a much better
person over it and I began to it began
to come up in conversation with people
and people very fascinated by it and
then they would implement some of the
things that I talked about and would
come back to me and say oh my gosh it
worked exactly as you said this is how I
revolve around psychology it's well it's
a psychology psychology specifically in
terms of relationships yeah and
particularly marriages yeah so this
information that I found like I said
it's all over the place so the the one
question that I got repeatedly was where
did you get this information how did you
learn this it's like well it's all over
the place that you know can
figured I'll put it all together well is
there something that is or a buck is
your video that I can read or watch and
unfortunately there isn't there is no
single place that I have found yet that
has put this information together in the
way that I have come to understand it
now there are other frameworks out there
there are other Muslims who who are in
this program are in that profession who
have come with from which are great and
this is just a different way to think
about it and the way and I'll tell you
what was one of them one of the game
changers for me was discovering that
when it comes to as men when we deal
with women discovering that what women
say they want is not necessarily what
they respond to emotionally that's very
important so those again as it's worth
repeating what women say they want yeah
it's not necessarily what they will
respond to emotionally and when I
discovered this it was in the context of
explaining why there's so much bad
information out there because what they
do is though they'll come and they'll at
they'll do surveys they'll do studies
and they'll they'll ask women about
their relationships what is it that you
want what is it that you want your
husband to do how do you want him to be
what kind of man are you looking for if
you're single bla bla bla all these
things and what happens is these women
they answer these questions truthfully
and genuinely but when they're asked
those questions they are not in the
midst of any emotion and any heightened
emotions they're pretty neutral women
are just as logical as men you know
so they give very reasonable logical
answers but what happens is when a
situation comes along that tweaks their
emotion they respond in a way that is
contrary to what they said when they
were in logical mode does that make
sense
so these are modules override the lay
override the logic so these studies
surveys and books are misleading because
they're based on answers from women who
are answering questions when they're in
logical mode so to speak
so understanding that was a big
game-changer for me because you read
articles you read books you watch videos
and you even speak to people speak to
women your mother is your aunt whoever
it is that gives you advice and it just
doesn't fit it just doesn't work and so
you find that there are some people who
have kind of caught on to this and start
to deviate from traditional relationship
and advice and counseling and start to
explore other ways and this is where all
this uh you know that's one of the game
changers for me and I just when I
explain this to men in these
conversations got out then it's kind of
the guys are thinking oh wow that's
really interesting and then it really
changes their approach and then I start
getting give examples of these things
and then when they implement it they
have a much better awareness a much
better understanding of why their wives
are behaving this way why is it that
when they do this it doesn't work so on
and so forth yes total GameChanger
what what do you mean there's some
things that you that you you write about
that are very very interesting if you
can elaborate on how women are
subconsciously wired to test men and
that you know they're not even aware
that they're testing them and the
constant consequences yes there's so
many good ones in there that's a very
good one so this is what they call
there's a there's there's two kinds of
subconscious tests one is called a
compliance test and the other one is
called a congruence test yeah basically
what this means is that so if we if we
if we go back to the days of the caveman
okay
the when women sought to be with a man
who made them feel secure who was a
provider it was all about physical the
taller bigger stronger man is the one
who would make them feel more safe and
protected
today that no longer applies so what we
have is we have a biology that is
fundamentally incompatible with the
social establishment of of today because
we're not in the food chain okay we
don't face these sort of like physical
natural challenges that we did in the
past so what gives a woman the feeling
of safety and security is no longer
about physical they can be with a guy
like me I'm a short guy I'm five foot
tall and that really doesn't even matter
now if I was living back then I would
have a hard time what matters is they
derive their safety from social
psychological means so what they do is
they evaluate a man in terms of how they
feel emotionally can is this is this man
emotionally and socially capable of
being a good protector and provider so
the way that they do this and it happens
naturally and I've seen it all the time
where men aren't really set up because
we're less of emotional beings and not
and not only because of that but because
we naturally are inclined to the
physical way of things we're all about
you know MMA and that kind of thing
so the the kind of tests that they do
and they do this
subconsciously so a congruence test for
example will be when a woman does
something that kind of rubs you the
wrong way and if you have an emotional
reaction over it then you're really not
as stable as you may seem to be yeah so
sometimes I could come across as like
you know challenging you with something
you know oh you know you know for
example it was one time where a person
said oh you know this ice cream is all
mine and she says oh you don't like to
share huh you know that's kind of like
sticking you with a little you know well
if you get taken aback by that then
you're having an emotional reaction
and if and if you have an emotional
reaction it's sort of a turn-off yeah
you know I mean you think the society
the times we're living it has taken like
there's a good documentary that talks
about the losing of the man like do you
feel in your studies that they talk
about how the society in the cloud
really just like taking the man out of
man there's no more men around there's a
a degradation of masculinity today and
that that's what's happening and there's
a lot of reasons for that but the effect
is is is this that men tend to have a
more more of an emotional reaction and
and by the way this was this was one of
my own weaknesses that I didn't
understand so that's so what happens is
if you're if you can't if you don't deal
with that properly you fail what's
called the congruence test yeah so
you're you're you're calm cool and
collected self is not congruent with
your internal emotional ability and if
you're in congruent there then it makes
it mix it makes her feel unsafe because
she doesn't know when you're gonna be
set off she doesn't know if you're going
to be snapping you know yeah so and but
they but you know when I when I talk to
women about this they're like do we
really do that like they don't even
understand even know that they do this
intuitively so women are what I like to
call emotional ninjas they're born with
it they just know I mean they are so
emotionally savvy they run circles
around us we are the ones that have to
acquire the knowledge we have to analyze
it in the way that we think and figure
it out so they do this subconsciously
the other one is called a compliance
test and a compliance test they this is
definitely definitely don't do this on
purpose this is when a woman will give a
man a directive and it could be any kind
of command or instruction and if they do
it then they're compliant well what
happens is subconsciously this means
that the man is not really leading you
not he's not in a position of leadership
and they'll never say this you know
they'll never say well he's a weak
leader if I tell him what to do and he
just obeys
it will never say it's just kind of like
an intuitive vibe and you know by
understanding that you know you catch
yourself you catch yourself doing these
things and portraying yourself as a weak
leader someone who doesn't have a
backbone you don't you can't stand up
for yourself you're a doormat all these
things happen and you know these are
subconscious tests that they do without
even realizing it that they just kind of
intuitively figure you out how about the
where you talk about good feminism bad
feminism yes you elaborate on that so
good feminism is when the idea that
women should have equal rights that
women should earn the same wage that men
do for the same task for the same job
that women have the right to vote on
property I mean these are all things the
right sort aslam do and yet exactly of
Islam is a very feminist friendly you
know way of life
bad feminism is when there is a
resentment associated with men having a
patriarchal society when there's this
resentment inside that causes women to
hate sort of hate the idea of a man
being in power or in leadership or even
hereditary yes exactly
this leads to the difference between
equity versus equality where equality
tries to make two things the same and
where equity tries to make things fair
so Islam prescribes equity acknowledging
that that men and women are equal we're
not in the same in our biology and our
nature we're just not the same type of
human so there can't be equality and you
know we hear things about like
transgender issues and bathrooms and all
that that's all about equality and and
standing up against that when it rubs
feminists the wrong way that's that's
the bad feminism where you try to
acknowledge or we're in this type of
feminism you reject
the nature of man the nature of the male
I should say and try to make the nature
of men and women the same because you
attributed to well men and women would
be the same if it wasn't for the society
that changes us yeah so I believe that
that's a bad feminism with his elite to
this like shaming of men for being men
and but the good feminism is that women
should be have equal rights and all of
these things that are that that belong
to them that's rightfully theirs but
they didn't have when you look back I'm
at a time when women were just like sold
as as as property and didn't have
couldn't even home property and couldn't
do any of the things you know it's long
gave those vices yeah I mean there's a
story of a oh ma it benefit AB Allah be
pleased with him who was the the second
caliph after Abu Bakr and after the
prophets passing and in in his story
goes that he was giving a Hoopa and a
woman stood up and corrected him on a an
error that he made in public and he
basically said you're right thank you
yeah you know this is unheard of in
metal-metal many medieval Europe or many
other societies around the world that a
woman can confront the leader of the
nation in public correct him and and he
was humble and accepted so that you know
this year you're absolutely right
because were well-established in Islam
many years ago those are one of the
challenges we're dealing with today
ignorant people who some just choose to
stay ignorant they don't come and
research and look into it because just
the fact that more women are coming to
Islam than men right is a fact in and of
itself that these women have done the
research no one's forcing them to come
to Islam they are doing out of their own
free will and that negates totally this
absurd you know fallacy that Islam
somehow oppresses the woman actually
liberate sir we're almost we're almost
out of time so we talked touched upon
why you came to Islam and then now
you're really in this realm of
relationship kind of like ablation ship
guru would you say someone who's like I
like to think of the relationship
coaching coaching pitch right what's
your vision with this before we end what
is you and I maybe in the future we can
common we can we can elaborate more so
my vision is to take this framework and
these principles and eventually create a
frontline what I like to call a
frontline of relationship coaches who
can understand and respond to the issues
the crises that we have in marriages to
become educated consumers of therapy and
counseling there just aren't enough
counselors there aren't enough scholars
who are who have degrees and have gone
to school and have studied this for
their lives there aren't enough of them
to respond to all of the people having
crisis in marriage I was one of them so
what I hope to create is a framework
that allows more people to to benefit
from this information so that they don't
have to necessarily find you know a
counselor or when they do go to
counseling they're much more savvy
they're much more educated and efficient
consumers of that help so think of it as
like an army of assistance to these you
know counselors who are overwhelmed with
people that have crises and also you
know coaches who can respond to it
without because you know a lot of people
can't afford going to counseling so it
also has to do with you know the
financial the financial challenges of
seeking this kind of help a lot of
insurance policies won't cover this kind
of thing people are you know it might go
away now with what's happening today
with the Trump administration and in
health care so a couple more points in
your in your studies in your pursuit of
knowledge in this area the countless
hundreds of articles and videos and
relationship experts that you've
listened to have you and I've also gone
down this route I've always been able to
somehow maybe someone didn't elaborate
or articulate the Islamic message it may
be you saw some some Imam or someone
didn't the same way as let's say another
person who is not Muslim but in many of
these valuable points did you see that
there's there's you can find some hadith
or ayah somehow you can connect it back
did you see the psychology how its long
tack absolutely absolutely so for
example while there are so many examples
give us one before we leave sure I'll
give you one I'll give you one that goes
to the core of what we talked about yeah
about the internal values right there's
an eye on the Quran it says Allah will
not help someone unless they help
themselves
Yeah right there's also many times that
he says in the Quran o you who have
wronged your own Souls there's another
example over there many examples where
actually here's a very good one anywhere
anytime
you read in the Quran that Allah
describes those who are successful it is
every without without fail it is
associated with internal values those
who are chaste those who are remember
Allah often those who are patient those
who are perseverant those who are
charitable who treat the orphans well
it's always associated with some type of
internal value these are the ones who
are successful what are the ones who
will you know reach Jenna however it is
it is worded but whenever he talks about
anything that's external it's always
associated with you know doom the most
famous example is in surah tauba when he
talks about if your houses if your
spouse's if your children if your
business is for which you fear a decline
in revenues if these things are more
important to you than Allah and His
Messenger then know that there's a day
that will come that he will judge you
and Allah does not love the
transgressors and so on and so forth so
whenever you see external factors
they're always associated with you know
warnings and consequences
whenever you see internal factors is
always associated with with success and
this goes back to and really what it is
is it's it comes back to the concept of
self esteem which is a very
misunderstood concept and we could have
just a whole session just on that one
but it comes to the core of it
and I can go on and on and on about
other examples well it was a pleasure
talking with you meeting you and
inshallah we can we continue our
conversation and shall I was it was good
it was a pleasure thank you so much for
being with us thank you yeah do you have
have you have do you have a website or I
do not have anything yet what I what I
hope to do actually is to test this
concept by means of some type of men's
support group a sort of Brotherhood sort
of gathering that I can introduce these
concepts for anyone who's interested yes
and if it works if it's something that
that they find beneficial then I would
like to you know move forward that
finish the book and formally create a
framework and a website and all that so
right now I feel like I'm I'm more in a
pilot test mode all right thank you
thank you and thank you guys for tuning
in as he said look the crater of the
heavens in herve he talks about saying
that Allah the Almighty will not change
the condition of a people until they
change within themselves you have to
take those necessary steps towards the
Creator towards God towards Allah make a
conscious effort to make a change and
then put your trust in the Almighty and
he will facilitate a way of ease what if
you're not even calling upon your
Creator like we talked about earlier I
mean like Ricardo did he called upon God
and asked for guidance we need it every
single day in our life what if you demon
I was talking to one gentleman he said
look I'm here if God wants me he can
come he knows where I'm at I mean what
kind of what kind of rebellious nature
is this you have to humble yourself you
have to earnestly beseech his help and
you have to want to know why you've been
created while you're here and where
you're going with your done so why don't
you do a Ricardo did I mean
that very simple ask the creator for
guidance and if you're on that guidance
value it and earnestly pray that you
don't lose it and continue to develop a
relationship with your Creator if you're
tuning in for the first time call us
you